die usa müssen ihre worte noch über 20
jahre wieder treffen
30 intensiv und sigrid sand
[Musik]
das hat sie mir nie fremd heimat
trotzdem ukraine lehrer
[Musik]
unter jens reiss mit seiner frau schon
hinter marlies heimatland china
im moment ist quasi bevor der sturm
wir werden sehr viele freundschaften und
sehen in china und
ich lass mich überraschen dass sonst
kommt
das ist trug zu den wurzeln 30 freund
hein und
[Musik]
am hallwilersee im kanton aargau das
sind die jetzigen sich frauchen ihn mit
ihrem dürfte realisiert
nun gehts los mit der reise die
fremdheit kino.de jens ist mit
chinesischer eltern in kanada
aufgewachsen und nun jetzt in ob sie
jetzt wo die eigentliche wurzel
kennenlernen
wichtig zu wissen ja woher meine eltern
kommen und so wie sie aufgewachsen sind
als das ist etwas das mich wundert oder
ganz ganz anders aufgewachsen sind auf
herz wie ich aufgewachsen bin einfach
ganz spannend was passt auf unser
zukunft geheimen im chinesisch und da
wissen sie heute greifen nicht mehr
greifen - asiatischen ufer und schoss
noch weniger grund doch irgendwie zu
sein chinesisches lohan und dann haben
wir punkten müssen wir gleich mal
erzählen über das niveau hat auch sehr
einfach und so wusste finden momentan
ist sie in die mutter für das bordbuch
ferien in china und ausruhen erwarte
dass jeder sohn und schwiegertochter
endlich auch mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ok
[Musik]
am jens daniel trentino vor seiner
geburt verloren und sich das mühsam
aufgebaute software zusammen mit zwei
geschwistern aufgewachsen
[Musik]
vor 18 jahren hätte jens john ihn
kennengelernt oder monster und felix ist
der wahlbezirk ist große liebe wurde
darum ist die jens sie vor kurzem zu
dass schon in die schweiz zog
aber sie nie richtig heimat die er bis
heute nicht geklärt
den gebäuden ab gewachsen aber immer mit
so weiß der menschen oder und dann wenn
wir platz italien hongkong wenn nur neun
und in china weiß pink wird kohl schon
schon ganz ganz anderes aus
muss er bitter ist keine klärt über und
federvieh klimaauflagen ist ja häufig
sind nur noch nie genau ob sie unter dem
namen oder so und man wird ja aber du
bist aber du kannst auch honig die
bereitet
die zone 2 truhen orientierte moment mit
seiner familie extrem wichtig erzählte
freunden mit vielen von ihnen älter als
ich aufgewachsen bin habe ich nicht so
wahnsinnig viel zeit mit meiner eltern
beigebracht haben ihre eigene rest land
gehabt und dann ist echt heftig so was
wie viele stunden man so in der küche
und einkaufen verbraten muss
ich denke gut klar
[Musik]
hauptsache es kommt darauf an welche für
die zukunft geschaffen aber zum das land
soweit wir haben jetzt nichts soll waren
sie eigentlich beziehung natürlich würde
hätte ich es ist immer meine werden
immer meine eltern sein und so und meine
wenn ich ich ich sehe sie auch nur ein
paar tagen jahre mein vater vielleicht
ein nachmittag im jahr höchstens und das
50 dank dass auch normalerweise lisa so
aber ist für die seinem 17
dirie alicia macht wie drei mit sie
blieb peter große auftritte schweiz für
janine unter jens i got more los zuerst
mal auf hongkong
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so läuft
[Musik]
rochester der ostküste vor der usa das
ist sexy posen aus dem kanton glarus
ziehen auch ihr vater der donald wieder
getroffen
dieses baby xiii wo sich ihre eltern
trennten und mutter mit ihrer zurück zu
jedem wort trezzini richtige beziehungen
aufbauen
[Musik]
denn
der donald wieder kühler und 212 darüber
wo der kontakt zu ihrem vater jahn peine
jahr praktisch abbruch
aber die letzten tagen die zwei einander
brachten tag bevorzugen wieder pflückt
vater und tochter zu den erfahren
[Musik]
die breite sind forward some at sea
mac user so
mit ihnen sieht sie erwachsen und jesuit
mit ihrem vater verbraucht wie der
letzte tag
ich habe ihn besser kennen kann
wie er ist
relativiert wissen wir wie sich das mit
dem
später grund doch
oder intense
[Musik]
die wm mission
obwohl johnny kühlkissen erleichtert
ich konnte gewiss der bücher gewünscht
werde
wie die trägen mischt sich nur dem islam
solches für die jüngste oder und hat
sehr viel interpretation fläche über bis
zu das persönliche und pionier wünscht
sie
der berg machen
und ich will weitermachen
gärtner 50
30 die fremdheit täter suchen antworten
braucht wo sie sehr lang gesuchte tiere
vater endlich besser kennengelernt
[Musik]
gute nachrichten in zollikofen team ok
einreisebewilligung sind noch lange
nicht
[Musik]
gut acht stunden tabus in orte vom iran
aus der stadt rund 7 vater des nachts um
2 uhr zimmer und ihre mann der emo
landet und trotzdem werde der rufe
verwandt die auf die zwei freunde
familienmitglieder aus der schweiz
[Musik]
in erinnerung geblieben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
entwickelt wurde die software dein
körper 45 liter flughafen und fast ganze
familie das ist ja unglaublich verloren
die stirn schlussendlich am flughafen
und die schweiz meldet sich dass sie mal
vater wird wisse ob sie dort auch aber
das muss man worte mittlerweile ist es
morgen und ruhm
[Musik]
müssen sie da
die dame ihre wurzel sind die sabres
land wo wieviel in uetersen unfall angst
und unsicherheit auslöst
[Musik]
huber zusammenkunft kam mit der familie
weg fragt was soll man machen wenn er
zurückkommt meter ging das spiel mehr
wird sie also nach romantik sie und was
mache ich hier eigentlich ist richtiger
im zimmer bereit die entscheidung nicht
nach dem empfang am flughafen fühlte
sich gut auf gruppe und der straffung
von 100
[Musik]
audienz und janine sind mittlerweile
auch im tatort kilometer infante
hongkong
dollar
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
die tochter alicia ist nunmal erik bruhn
ist sie der heimat blieben die jens sie
macht die reise nie fremd heimat nicht
nur für sich selber sondern auch für
kollision richtig dass ich meinen
eigenen herzens trennen
meine bin noch nie in china oder
wirklich in die asiatische raum
überhaupt es auch sicher dass ich das
später mit tagen etwas was nicht
mitteilen kann mit mit betriebsrat
informierte weiß sehr wenig und spd über
die familie und das sieht eine lücke
gefüllt waren auch weil ich sie auch
verfilmt werden
bis vor 20 jahren schwankungen britische
kolonie mit görtz durch china
die metropole verspricht viel ivanovic
schweiz der jensen und jon in wörrstadt
auf eigene faust entdecken
[Musik]
so einig und dem ist madonna im prinzip
mit dir aber die menschen hatte
ich hoffe nicht
projekt
links
eine warnung mit dem baum samt richtigen
platz
ich bin zu spannen durch diese methode
die sie in schwindelerregender höhe
auseinandergebrochen das gericht mit
[Musik]
mit ein bisschen nett
stadtzentrum wird vom victoria harbour
trend auf der halbinsel kowloon der
anderen schwankung island
[Gelächter]
victorias pik
so einzelne wörter kann ich erkennen
aber kein kindern oder und auch die
wichtige werte kann ich wahrscheinlich
nicht der jens economies kantonesisch
braucht sprach aber nur selten mit dem
klima in der stadt davids kampf für drum
wenn der jens i und janine husberg
verankerung
[Gelächter]
flugpause so viele sachen mit hits wie
die lieder heißen sommertag bei 90
prozent
zum glück fordert bahnhof die prüfung
victoria peak
[Musik]
der yen sie entdeckt hongkong als
tourist persönliche beziehung zu der
backend aber zwischen idealer ort zum
zaubern turiner arts von hongkong ist im
vergleich zum restlichen nämlich sehr
westlich
ja
doch entlassen
[Musik]
am anderen fuß chinesische festland der
dann erwarteten jens in die
vergangenheit sehr viel verwandschaften
und china und
[Musik]
ich lass mich überraschen schon morgen
wird sich der 43 jährige nach seinen
wurzeln machen dass die gang antworten
finden auf den sachen und völlig
antworten finden auf fragen bisher noch
nie weiß dass es tage sind also das ist
einfach viel viel leerer platz erfülle
mit geschichte mit erfahrungen mit größe
und mit gerichten mit al asisija pro
jahr so offen und freundlich gesinnt
[Musik]
40 grad kälter und das paar tausend
kilometer weiter westlich das ist der
bisher größte stadt im iran
[Musik]
zu der 1,5 millionen lütow dollar bietet
verwandtschaft von simon ihre ford
roadster es gewohnt bevor die sache
realistisch
10 52 statt die unter einer gewinn sind
im iran blieben
doch der erste kurzen 18 zimmer und remo
hüthum begrüßungsfest ihrem onkel j
das ist ne wie seh das immer ihre
cousine die beiden einzig foto es klare
der schweiz zeit maximal hat nobitz mit
hüpfburg und das thema nicht wie sieht
es hier nicht wieder her immer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hongkong thonig zeigte sie muss ihre
gemeinsame vergangenheit mit 80 macht es
bewahrt es ist unglaublich hier jetzt
lebt mehr trotz politischer ja
unglaublich bist du verrückt eigentlich
immer dass sie dank ihrer griff an kraft
verschenkt sie was wir wissen ja wie
groß ist die technik ist aber nicht die
einzige erinnerung ruft 8
bei uns blüht sie keine verboten sind
repariert denn für sie und die heizung
aus
mit gäste-keeper kann
hallo
[Musik]
empfangskomitee vom flughafen
jetzt wird es sicher noch mal bewusst
wie riesig ihre verwandtschaft ist
[Musik]
frauen des fahrstraße vorbereitet
traditionell wird die sonne große runde
am boden kasse
[Musik]
grossartig
ja der druck erhöht und die vermutungen
und serviert es ist auch spannend und im
schluff drin und haben immer noch eine
chance
[Musik]
das ist fantastisch aber das muss doch
lieber ort des sinai verwandte wenn die
schweiz nicht nur kulinarisch verwöhnen
sondern auch mit ironischen folklore
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am nächsten tag kino.de entziehen die
frau fahre durch chinesische festland
den tisch momentan aber jens die mutter
tierchen nur schön aussehen
ich habe häufig und wenn denn alle die
ganz familie und chinesischen dass ich
meistens selber den flug und relativ
einheitliche gerät und danke für deine
beiden ist schon in südchina gegend rund
um jens in die mutter sie wohnt 40 yards
kanada 100 rheinische im jahr für das
paar wochen auf china
der vater von mir und sie ist immer um
schafe in kanada und sucht seine heimat
nicht so oft
das ist richtig
also ich liebe es gibt gar nicht denn
sie ist kanada aufgewachsen
für ihn ist china als komplett fremdes
land bankrott ihrer mutter wenn sie
clean aufzufrischen
viel schöner aus sich wartet habe
ehrlich gesagt so aus rundum war ja
akzeptabel so aber ich hatte mir gesagt
es ist schön war aber richtig
tschechien hat glück dass sie
gleichzeitig mit ihrem sohn friesi wird
mieter wie nazis heimatland generiert
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
frühstückskorn oder boni zufriedener
kreist und mailin komisches gefühl das
ich jemals
die ganze ja ich bin wirklich positiv
überrascht etwas gesagt city von wall
street wo andere die sich familien
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zurück im iran noch im turbulenten
empfangstresen zimmer und 26
[Musik]
ch
am renault ist eine erste tag im iran
einiges klar boot ist also eigentlich
fragt ja aber ich sage ich jetzt nicht
wie gefordert es so ich sagen wollte ich
sehen elvis und ich eine so extrem
extrem vorliegen und wie ich das
natürlich
[Applaus]
die zwei sind sv horn und wertvoller
moschee georgisch im 16 jahrhundert für
königsfamilie gebaut wurde ist bekannt
für die einzigartige akustik
das haben sollten
bis 6 das erzählen aber auch mit segen
ist
die majestät die stühle driburger
britisches architektonisches meisterwerk
und das wahrzeichen der stadt
[Musik]
timo und remo knie sieht zweisamkeit die
seele erkennen als richtiger bisher
[Musik]
obwohl sich die zwei meter an sehr
willkommen fühlt mit timo mit dass kopf
durchgeben betrachtung von der heimat
rennen
sie haben auf verkündet worden
[Musik]
die ganz familie schon der wachs amtlich
kardashian ambiente ihre heimatstadt
drescher und zeigen die 2009 je 2 max
[Musik]
obergeschoss mit sightseeing tour los
cottbus wichtige erledigen
das gehört alles zum eine uralte rituale
[Musik]
habe ich noch nie gemacht oder und so
ich muss aufholen und 34 jahren und
untersten geben dass es dann richtig ist
so viele jahre unimog für bleibt
zusammen
die jens seine vorfahren im jenseits
zwei millionen yen in falschgeld und
dessen bett steht plötzlich janine im
mittelpunkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie wurde dort zusätzlich gab so weiß
nicht wie viel ist auf 60 personen 60
fotos machen
max malsch tatsächlich der jens im
mittelpunkt
[Musik]
bin so froh dass wir das wir gesehen
haben dass das virus unter herzen
bleiben
sie machte die iranische kultur
nicht die fehler farbe hier muss mich da
sehr viel nachwuchs ohne bh und sie
trifft am schluss von der rice ihren
vater
was ich fühle dass die großartigen
moment ist mein leben
[Musik]